what do you say to americans especially  immigrant americans who came to the  united states  looking for political stability and  seeing all the things that the president  is doing  hang on i'm on my way that's what i say  to them  not a joke and what the president's  doing now is uh  is really um  it's going to uh  be another incident where he will go  down in history  as being one of the most irresponsible  presidents in american history  it's it's just out of the  not even within the norm at all there's  questions whether it's even legal  it's hard to fathom how this man thinks  and it's hard to fathom  i i'm confident he knows he hasn't won  and is not going to be able to win and  we're going to be sworn into january  20th  and i just uh you know but  far for me to question his motive it's  just it's just outrageous what he's  doing